[Music]
let's go to jenny
from the block in serotonin saratoga
springs what's up jenny
hi dr d how are you
i'm good how are you doing we are
rocking it on man what's up
um so i guess the short of it is
my
my grandparents live next door
and they
moved somebody into their backyard
who like in a camper in their backyard
who has an addiction problem
and
um
i
need help
figuring out how to protect my family in
that
whole situation
because not like
i don't have a problem with people who
have addictions obviously like that's a
whole other jenny why do you hate
america i'm just kidding i'm just
i'm piling onto your own shane that
you're yeah take that off um clearly
you've identified a safety issue okay
doesn't mean that
that you hate people that are
they're struggling with addiction that
means that you're trying to keep your
family safe
so what what what about the situation
makes you feel unsafe
um
well
this person
stabbed someone
that's it
and
now he's living in my backyard oh
there's that
geez talk about overly sensitive jenny
um yeah
so
what's what's the addiction
heroin
gosh
so
uh i have been accused of being overly
compassionate and i've been accused of
being full of leftist propaganda because
my default setting is to love people and
to welcome them into my house rather
than kick them out
i totally get that and 100
i would not be okay
if a violent heroin addict moved into my
grandparents house next door to me in a
camper
yeah i got little kids do you all have
kids exactly wearing that
i have a three-year-old yes okay so what
is the connection between your
grandparents and this this
um this
backyard resident
um he is
the grandchild of their friends
and his so
his grandparents passed away so i think
that they feel like they owe it to
his grandparents to like take care of
him okay
hmm all right so
this situation is one of those that's
most of us will not have um
stabbing heroin addicts living next door
to us
particularly in our grandparents
backyard and a camper but this is one of
those
outside the bell curve situations that
we all deal with
especially when it comes to family and
that is
setting up boundaries that are that are
pretty firm
and so
i think it's you and your husband
sitting down and is is dad in the
picture
i just assumed that i shouldn't do that
okay dad's in the picture is y'all
sitting down and saying
um
where are our boundaries here and
boundaries may be as long as that person
is living next door
us and our kids will not go to my
grandparents house
we will refuse to go over there
um if this person is somebody you can
have a conversation with it might be
saying hey
um
we understand that you're living here
for a season in my grandparents backyard
um
it's not okay for you to come over to
our house or maybe you wait until that
person does try to come over to your
house say hey this is private property
we'd prefer if you don't come on to our
house is that a conversation awkward
absolutely is it hard and ugly and messy
absolutely
um might your grandparents revolt and
say well then forget you and i'm gonna
leave our house and all my money to this
this guy in the back maybe
but it comes down to a safety
conversation that you and your husband
feel safe you could also get together
your husband and say hey we're gonna go
knock on this person's door and invite
them out to coffee around our fire pit
and say
ask them what's been going on in their
life and if there's some you all can
decide what that is right but you all
get on the same page and then
here's the hard part communicating that
to your grandparents with respect and
dignity not just lobbying grenades right
have you talked to them
yes i um i went over there and i said i
was talking my grandfather is like
ninety percent deaf in one ear and he
can't hear any other one so he was
watching the race with his head set on
so he couldn't hear me and i was talking
to my grandmother which is an easier
conversation
and so i was like hey grandma like do we
have a timeline on how long this guy is
going to be living out back um and she
was like no i don't really think he does
either
and i was like oh that's
you know
like what are we gonna do about that if
that turns into a problem well it turns
it is like it will turn into forever
yeah that's what i'm afraid of and she
said um that's the thing about because
we just bought my parents house that was
my parents house and we just bought it
okay um
and so
she said that's the thing about
homeownership you have to learn to live
with your neighbors
and i just dude hey bit my tongue on
that one that's a great grandma line
right there that's like grandma burn
right there that's awesome
oh dude that's awesome good job for your
grandma so here's here's grandma just
put her boundary down this person's
living here you need to suck it up and
get over it
that's not what you want to hear but
that's what you got and so she actually
is right you all get to decide what
happens next are we going to sell mom
and dad's house at full market value and
head out because we don't want our kids
living here are we going to wait until
there's a problem are we going to
address it head-on you all get to decide
what comes next just recognize
that what comes next is going to be
uncomfortable there's not really a way
around that and just because it's
uncomfortable doesn't mean it's wrong
okay right
um
if i'm in your situation and you've
already had the conversation with
grandma
probably what i would do is be very
proactive about reaching out
i would go meet the person to the guy
yes
the way you just said unless this person
is scary right or to complain
[Music]
he's just like not all there
so
i don't know how i don't even know how
that conversation would even
go like i'm knocking on a camper in my
backyard like hey
like that but again you want a beer
i mean yeah
that's probably what i would do quite
honestly but um
here's another thing you might try
is writing your grandparents a letter
because your dad your granddad can read
that he might not hear it but you can
read it
and just say hey i love you
i am nervous as your granddaughter
living next door to somebody who
has a violent history
and who is making me and our little one
feel unsafe
so here's what we're gonna do until then
um y'all are welcome to come to our
house if you'd like to
but we just don't feel safe right now
and if you're gonna choose to have this
person live in your backyard over us
that's great that's your home
and write it down because two things
happen when you write something down
like that number one it helps you you
have to clarify it here's what my actual
problem is and we tend to be like that
guy's a that guy's a
conservative i ain't talking to that
well what is the actual problem with the
politic right what are the things that
are driving you it makes you identify it
and then the second thing is it gives
the reader an opportunity to read it
have their body respond to it they're
going to get angry they're going to get
self-righteous and whatever and they can
go back to it and they can go back to it
and then go back to it and
then they can be like actually we're
choosing this over this and at least we
can have a conversation about it right
so that would be my recommendation write
a letter to your grandparents and then
move on
the more you pull into your driveway and
look over the fence and get raged out
and hate and all that
you are gonna choose to make your life
miserable
and the more you drive and look and
you're always scanning
your child is going to pick up on that
that three-year-old is going to pick up
on that and they're going to think
there's something scary and unsafe about
mom and about our house and
you're just going to create a cascade
there so
um
yeah you're in a messy situation i'm
sorry that's hard
um but your grandma's right your
grandma's right
i guess they're allowed to let somebody
live in their backyard with a camper
depending on your deed restrictions
wherever y'all live and you all have to
now make some choices about what y'all's
life is going to look like or what
life's going to look like moving forward
hate y'all got put in that situation um
man i hate that their compassion
is may end up costing them their house
it makes me hard to evict somebody down
the road all those things
sounds like a mess and um to be clear
have some good boundaries and uh holler
back
something go sideways i'd love to hear
about it